Speaker 1: gs are going well for Trump, he
supports Trump.
But then on the night of January six, he said,
it's over.
It's time to move on.
Okay.
He Lindsey Graham was subpoenaed in the Georgia
grand jury investigation of Trump's attempt
to overturn to Steele, let's call it what
it is to steal the Georgia electoral votes.
Lindsey Graham, upon receiving the subpoena,
said, I'm going to fight this subpoena.
His lawyers used all sorts of different arguments
and a judge has said, no, you've got to show
up.
Let's take a look at this NBC News report.
A judge ordered Senator Lindsey Graham to
testify in front of a special grand jury in
Georgia investigating former President Donald
Trump's alleged attempts to overturn the results
of the 2020 election.
Fulton County Superior Court Judge Robert
McBurney ordered that Graham will be required
to testify August 2nd.
The judge's certification, filed Monday, describes
Graham as a necessary and material witness
to the grand jury probe.
The development was reported earlier by WSB
TV.
Graham's office did not immediately respond
to requests for comment.
The senator's attorney said last week he would
not comply.
The grand jury also subpoenaed members of
Trump's former legal team, including personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani.
Now, one of the arguments that Lindsey is
lawyers made in this entire thing is that
his actions in calling Georgia officials to
ask what's going on, can we get the right
count, whatever he was doing, the argument
his lawyers made was that Lindsey's actions
are protected under these constitutional safeguards
for members of Congress not getting punished
for their speech or actions performed in the
course of their legislative duties.
So to explain that in layman's terms.
The lawyers for Lindsay said.
When Lindsay called to inquire about those
election results, he was performing legislative
duties as a senator of the United States.
That probably sounds like B.S. to you.
And it is.
And both the D.A. and the judge said Graham
isn't a Georgia resident and Graham is not
a Georgia politician.
And U.S. senators don't have any legitimate
congressional function in personally calling
state election officials to argue about the
results or to suggest that the results might
be wrong.
It's it doesn't make any sense.
It's not right.
As a senator, he has no role there.
He has no standing.
He's not a voter.
So he can't use that argument.
What he was doing was he was trying to trade
on his name and influence by calling and saying,
hey, this is Lindsey Graham.
I'm a U.S. senator.
I'm paying attention to what you're doing.
Don't you think maybe you could review the
results and maybe see if they weren't right?
But there was no legitimate legislative function
as a U.S. senator being served there.
And unfortunately, the judge agreed with that.
You don't get to choose which laws you would
like to follow.
I mean, sometimes these people in power do.
But you shouldn't get to anyway.
And Lindsey Graham, at least for now.
And we'll see if he appeals the decision,
if it's subject to appeal or what he tries
to do between now and August 2nd.
In principle, he is supposed to show up and
testify on August 2nd.
I know that clearly his lawyers don't want
him to.
That's why they tried every possible argument
to get him out of it.
And if indeed he does testify, it should be
absolutely fascinating.
We will have the clips and more of the stories
that we talked about in the segment on The
David Pakman Show Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman Show.
Also, follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
The the hate voicemail I posted yesterday.
Incredible reaction.
I think close to a thousand comments on it.
Listen to it on my Instagram David Pakman.
Let me know what you make of it.